thank you
[Music]
all right let's talk about what the [__]
we're gonna talk about the werewolves
let's talk about the room let's talk
about what could possibly be going on
with the Fallout from the Ohio it's an
attack on America dude no I tell you
okay
all of these [__] were built
around the same time so then they're
withering away at the same time are they
really built around the same time
no but then my language
don't look into it I had to get the
transmission changed and then the
mechanic told me oh that's been kind of
happening because they're all built
around the same
three five years so all of that model
around that time
that's right you're applying Your Land
Cruiser mechanics Theory oh railroad
medicine bro oh God all right we got
that theory because the Chinese built
the railroads all at the same time and
they're trying to destroy us from the
inside oh so they basically like built
it to be like a ticking time bomb
Shanghai Noon it was a marvelous
historical piece great right John Wayne
uh
no he calls himself oh yeah anyways
John Wang okay
um that historical film taught us that
Chinese play such a long game they're
like first we are going to build a
railroad in America it sounds so
medicine right and then a hundred years
later we're gonna go and plant
Absolution so when they built it they
had a little screw loose and they're
like I said 100 years I was going to
break and then the guy's like Mr White
[Laughter]
dude 100 years from now
I'm not even alive anymore to reap the
benefits dude that's that's the China
long game dude their game is so long
it's long dude that's why the name is
Long yeah because we played a long game
[__]
no joke there's a uh there's a Chinese
building glasses are off it's no joke
time no joke there's a Chinese the
character's over the Chinese billionaire
okay okay and he seek he's seeking
asylum in the US of a and he's like you
guys don't [__] him no dude China plans
[__] out for like hundreds of years
ahead while you guys are fighting over
here like Republican Democrat [__] and
trying to like you only plan five years
ahead here he goes but over there
they're like they're gonna Dominate and
you better watch out and I'm just trying
to live my life here in the U.S because
they're gonna [__] control they've
been planning this balloon attack for 40
years that's what I'm saying
so what do you think is a reason for all
of the uh lack of addressing can you
catch the classroom up with like uh all
the variables real quick like where yeah
the timeline of these railroads right
the the informative man do it I want to
guess okay fine we have the East
Palestine uh Rail train derailment in
Ohio
Palestine that means good morning in
Japanese
I don't know how they say it locally but
uh so the train derails
a bunch of toxic chemicals were on this
train
the uh authorities decided to rather
than rush in and clean it up they should
just let it burn out
so it causes massive toxic cloud over
the town all the people in the town were
instructed to leave or be arrested
journalists who came to cover the crash
were also told to leave or be arrested
what they didn't want anybody looking
into nothing they were like nice why do
trains just have toxic chemicals just
chilling in their tanker I think train
is probably the only way you can
transform toxic chemicals right which is
why they got those giant black tankers
that have the [__] poisonous [__] on
the outside of it yeah yeah yeah I see
those on the way to Vegas sometimes yeah
but whenever I think of toxic ooze I
think Ninja Turtles yeah so I'm like
ggri what is the purpose what do they
use this for you know are they making
like or is it just waste yeah what is it
for tow car and razar again like I don't
really know what the application I mean
I'm sure there's a million different
uses so so this one happens in East
Palestine Ohio when was this
two weeks ago a week ago well eight
months ago judging by this upload nice
thanks for following us join our patreon
but then are these other places that the
train derailments are happening at are
they also toxic chemicals yeah what was
the next one there was another one or
was it like feathers or something what's
this happen none of the other I don't
think any of the other derailments that
happened this one's confetti no toxic
chemicals were released but it derailed
yeah so the train I mean the Amtrak [__]
like our trains look old though bro that
[__] looks like it needs a little bit of
an update you know so you don't see any
foul play in any of this Chinese well
what other uh states are this happening
uh I have to look it all up the common
denominator to me is they're in white
people States
wow isn't that all of them
also
also it's like is this one of those
things that we're just like we don't
normally pay attention to train deal
derailment so because it's heightened by
this like obviously [__] up oil or or
chemical ones that now everybody's
paying attention we're like oh this is
trendy realm it's everywhere or is this
like you know what I mean remember when
it's like dude kovitz got like two
million people nobody's got the flu that
year next year it's like yo the food's
back with two million people nobody's
got covered like a confirmation bias
yeah okay everyone's Southeast Michigan
and Arizona wow oh they're all random no
they're white people staged they are all
Norfolk Southern train company so one
train coming so it's them [__] up no
dude there's only like one train company
anyway oh that's true there's like less
than three that's true yeah maybe
they're just being mismanaged is it like
an insurance thing you know what I mean
why
I heard I was reading something about
how
I guess they weren't getting enough
inspections
on these trains because they pour yeah
or there's like yeah whatever you know
just typical business as usual and then
because of that all these issues are
starting to happen like the loose screw
from the Chinese Guys these are all
within the span of two weeks by the way
that's what would you remember La the
trains that were getting robbed to yeah
oh yeah all the Amazon packages on the
ground I could see that from my place I
lost some [__] in that holy [__] because
like you know remember where like the
train passes by the freaking gym yeah so
like uh our neighbors at the brewery
that are higher up on the building they
film they posted on the um on the
brewery page they could just film people
jumping over the wall and see into UPS
it's a straight Jet and then just
jacking everything and they just throw
it they throw all the packages over the
wall and then they climb back over and
they just leave nobody comes running no
alarm goes off no nothing and then right
along I'll tell you that wall is the
train yard where all of the shipping
containers pause to be like transferred
yeah yeah and you could that same wall
that they're done up and over you can
just go in there too and then they just
like crowbar open a door sometimes it's
not even closed you can see it that some
of these things are open Yeah well yeah
some of them you can just throw away and
ride yeah because they're not fully
closed right damn and they could be
sitting there for however long but then
yeah there's so many videos of that on
our Brewery page for like for all the
residents to be like hey does anyone
want to do anything about this like
maybe like he's like I've submitted
every one of these videos to the cops
they don't they can't do anything
man I remember cops would hassle your
ass if you go down there and try to
paint on it yeah if you're painting on
it for some reason that's worse but
they're not even stealing packages from
train cars or stealing whole wood power
we were doing um photos we were doing
photos at the train yard near his house
oh yeah and then the there's specific
uh LAPD or sheriff or whatever just for
the trains that's why I think it's like
a pay grade thing it's like if somebody
was let's say let's say I'm in there
taking like or doing tick tocks like a
guard is gonna be like I can handle that
but if I'm like if I'm with five other
dudes and we're throwing this package
over I could see him going that's not my
problem but nothing like the police yeah
like there's train police yeah but
they're not even gonna they're not
responding to it that's so weird like
there's a whole like you know like you
see on a whole train car it's just
Stacks in stacks of two by fours or like
wood yeah dudes are walking out with
that wow they're they're as a stealing
Lumber into a pickup just pull like
because then you know all you'd have to
do is just cut the ties or whatever and
then you could just like hand it to the
next guy and it looks like a
construction site but it's just a stop
train wow it's trippy dude yeah yeah so
is the anomaly back to all these chain
derailments the fact that it happened in
a short period of time uh and the only
real real what the [__] going on is
the one that has like chemical warfare
are going on and like acid rain yeah
that's the big thing and there was even
one big addressing it and we're sending
money to other countries for help but
then no one's rushing it never has
spoken on it no one's rushing to send
billions of dollars there to help and
and nobody is getting assistance so all
the people there are they're on their
own and even weirder like this just
happened the other day there was a
report of uh of one of the residents
there right they got a person that's
there to test whether or not their
residence is under toxicity the person
said I can't come into your home and
test unless you sign this hands her a
paper with
um what's there's something at the
bottom that says no matter what we are
not responsible wow yeah so she has to
be able to waive their responsibility in
order for them to even help wow so that
what the [__] is that and then so they
she took a photo of that they were like
you can't keep this paper she was like
can I take a picture she takes a picture
of the uh news comes in she shows the
news the company responds and says oh
that was the wrong sheet of paper sorry
we meant to give you this one don't tell
nobody I'm crazy is that oh so it's just
a bunch of [__] it's a bunch of
[__] yeah it's like it's it's
basically what happens when an oil spill
happens it's almost the same thing oil
smell happens you either don't hear
about it and when you do the
repercussions are so minute yeah it's
very hush
wow and most of the efforts No One's
Gonna pay for this this is gonna be some
Aaron Brockovich [__] though because
like in a generation there's going to be
a class action lawsuit because nobody
can fix it now but until you see like oh
my kids got 16 fingers so that's
American Chernobyl so for the for the
companies they're just like okay let's
sweep this under the rug let's keep this
as high and let's let our children deal
with it later yeah because getting the
vaccine and then and there being a
closet says you can't sue if you have
any like issues if you die from the
vaccines it's like that's crazy yeah you
don't even know what you're putting in
yourself but then like in this same
thing they're like hey yeah we want to
start the efforts to like help you but
first
first it ain't on us yeah what the [__]
is that this sounds like a Stranger
Things episode like it started this is
the toxic waste started the mutant
footage of like Creek Water where they
like if you Stir It Up it starts to look
like gasoline oh I see that that lady
throws something in the river and it's
splashes
it looks like a glow stick it should be
like out of there well yeah these poor
people that live there now but they're
not getting any help too like to fully
uproot your life and try to does Flint
have clean water still at all probably
not I wonder how long it'll take for
like nature to heal all that [__] didn't
Elon something about that
because it's another one of those issues
that you would hear all the time about
but then you don't know and then there
was that one guy who developed uh like
that evaporator thing yeah right yeah he
made like a clean water machine for the
public and he put it out there and
anyone could just get water whenever
they want and someone [__] it up
somebody gotten the guts of it and
vandalized it and destroyed it pretty
good prank why because they thought it
was funny no that's the thing it's like
he thinks it's like some kind of
governmental thing that was like no we
want people paying for water we don't
want this
yeah so we could keep the problem like
who would [__] up a free thing that also
benefits everybody in the area unless
like Nestle was doing that to poor
countries oh they would take their water
supply they would buy all the water
supplies and then sell back the water to
the community that was getting it for
free they're like buying River routes
and just being like oh did you want did
you need that yeah that's [__]
gangster dude it's crazy it's like that
old film where the the the the the that
one guy controls all the the water and
then like the people that are going
through them Chinatown not Max they do
that
and they I think the the OG one it was
like uh it was like the it was like a
western
and then everyone copied it in the there
was even an animated one that copied it
it was the final Goes West the American
Tail no I'm serious they [__] they
stopped the water route anyways now
we're just getting into a [__]
cartoon I'm not gonna fight this
[Music]
foreign